it's great to be joined today by Peter
coffin who's the author of custom
reality and you also creator of several
youtube series such as very important
documentaries he's focused on how media
and culture are directed to serve the
interests of capital bringing accessible
analysis to as many people as will
listen and it's quite a few people
you're I very interested in your YouTube
channel which has developed quite a
following Peter what would you say is
sort of like your overarching political
philosophy that that informs the content
that you do well um two things III I
think of things some III when I read
there's a book called society a
spectacle I read that and it sort of
brought together a lot of things for me
I over the years have been very critical
of like fandom and how people follow
things things have very much changed
maybe not change but maybe more gone
into overdrive on that front and I feel
like that it's noticeable that it's
under the influence and in the benefit
of capital so I try to apply sort of a
Marxist critique to a less material at
least obviously material sector of sort
of what is going on in the world culture
society things like that and the other
thing is I am a socialist I believe in
socialist politics
I believe in collective ownership of the
means of production power to the workers
all of those type of things so I tried
to sort of hover between those things
but I also well I find that a lot of
what I do is influenced by what we often
call postmodern philosophers and things
like that as well so I guess you could
call me a mishmash of a bunch of crap so
you're like a postmodern is Marxist it
sounds like yes despite that being a
contradictory term I think that fairly
decently describes me so let's talk a
little bit about the socialism part
because we've been talking there's been
this
growing confusion which maybe you've
identified between overtures social
democrats and democratic socialism or i
guess what i sometimes call actual
socialism meaning common ownership of
the means of production do you know i
think what we'll get into some of the
specifics but to be totally clear you
you have no confusion because you said
you believe in the common ownership of
the means of production you are actual
socialists you're not a social democrat
correct i am not a social democrat i
think that a lot of people who are
saying democratic socialists are really
sort of advocating social democracy but
i don't know that that's their
underlying beliefs because i've never
talked to them obviously but yeah we do
see a lot of people who are putting
forward an agenda that is more or less
it's still capitalism but with a lot of
sort of left-leaning policies trying to
balance that out and I think that's
commendable I don't think that it's
wrong to do that I think that it's not
enough basically let's dig into that
because I recently did a story I
actually I are you familiar with the
economist Richard Wolffe yes yes so he
was my college professor when I was at
the University of Massachusetts Amherst
and I've had him on the show many many
many times and over time in following
him and others I've come to the
conclusion that I actually I really am a
social democrat like I'm not actually a
socialist I don't think that more the
long term the best sort of organization
of large societies would be total common
ownership of the means of production and
I have both sort of like a pragmatic
approach to that conclusion but also
more of a theoretical approach to that
conclusion so maybe to start with like
what would in your mind be the top
argument whether it's pragmatic or a
philosophical for actual socialism
versus social democracy I think that it
really okay so my main I think the thing
that makes it hard for me to just sign
on to social democracy is because it
leaves the door open so to speak for so
much of what we are experiencing at the
moon
sort of a neoliberal capitalism
obviously I think both you and I as a
social democrat and a socialist have a
lot to criticize there but as a social
democrat I think I'm not saying that
you're uninformed or misinformed or
anything like that I think that it's
perfectly valid to have any of your
viewpoints but I also think that there's
a certain door left open for capitalist
people who hoard wealth people who
concentrate power to remain in power and
over time as social democracy progresses
they can continue to erode things look
look at the NHS in the UK for instance
elements of it have been being
privatized at such a rate like is it so
much better than the United States
healthcare system yes and it has been
for a very long time
but over the last couple of decades
they've been doing so much in the way of
attempting to privatize certain services
of it and it's slowly undermining it and
you see the crisis going on with there's
not enough doctors there's not there's a
lot of things that are being undermined
by people by private interests people
who are lobbying people who are spending
money with politicians essentially I'm
oversimplifying a little bit but I guess
what I'm unsure of is you know what
you're describing hasn't happened in
Sweden which one could argue more
closely Alliance as an actual social
democracy I don't know that anybody
knows that the UK in total is a social
democracy although they've socialized
medicine specifically so I guess I'm
unsure about the value of pointing out
when a specific program has gone one way
or the other as sort of explaining to us
the merits or or lack thereof of a
broader socialist system if that makes
sense
mm-hmm that's I mean I think that that's
fair I don't think that I think that to
go the other way the window kind of
goals goes both ways on that because
it's worked in Sweden right does that
mean it's going to work anyway and
that's in my opinion not a great
argument on the part of a lot of people
who use it in bad faith to just dismiss
any social democrat or socialist
programs or ideas right
altogether but I mean it's worth
discussion and I I agree with you that
Sweden is certainly a better system than
say the United States and in a lot of
cases the United Kingdom at least from
my observations and I'm not going to
argue with you on that idea I just think
that I do think that it's more worth it
to have the power more evenly
distributed between the actual workers
and the actual people see it becomes a
matter of degree right because as a
Social Democrat I also think the power
should be more evenly distributed but
then it becomes a question of our how
evenly are we talking about and I think
I'll just put forward what my - the sort
of two areas that push me most strongly
to social democracy versus socialism and
see what you think number one is that if
you enforce that the means of production
must be owned in common that is an
authoritarian action to take and I don't
believe or at least I have not seen any
evidence although I'm willing to have my
mind changed that you will end up with
an egalitarian self-determining society
if you impose it in an authoritarian way
that's sort of number one right that's
like a fundamental problem I have with
with pure socialism the other one would
be and I'll give you both and then you
can choose either you know are both it
but to it to address the other one is
that when I see inequality is a problem
I don't see the solution total equality
because I don't know of any other place
in human endeavours where you actually
see that what I guess we would sometimes
call full equality of outcome what I
would like to see is what I imagine a
strong social democracy would do which
is you truncate maybe even significantly
that very high end and that very low end
and you also raise the median or the
mean but that seems much more in line
with how we see human achievement
distributed whether it's academic in
sports wherever I don't know of any
place where you would see the
distribution that socialism would impose
those are sort of like my two big
philosophical disagreements
well for number one I would say that
it's not so much I mean you could look
at it as an imposition or you can look
at it from the idea of organizing
collectively if we have people who are
unionized and who are creating
organizations and working together on
ideas is it necessarily opposing if it's
a large group of people demanding
ownership over the means of production
and not necessarily every single means
of production is owned specifically by
all but so much as the actual mechanical
ownership is the workers now that does
create I do think some serious questions
that more a narco communist type people
the the conquest of bread book sort of
answers some of them although I don't
know that I entirely agree with
everything said in in that book as well
but there's more of a less centralized
you to impose something it has to be
more centralized would we really be
talking about imposing it if we're not
talking about creating a large
organization that governs everyone I'm a
libertarian socialist I don't really
believe in this sort of vanguard take
down the government established a small
group of elites to dictate socialism
down to the masses it's sort of like a
practical thing right which is then if
you're not going to decree that it's not
government ownership right it's not
communism but if the government does
well free that you must have shared
ownership by by the workers then if
companies don't want to do it then all
of a sudden it's not actually socialist
right so like how do you actually make
it socialist well that's the interesting
question there's so many people who
disagree on so many different types of
social I you brought up Richard Wolfman
well he would tell you that there's a
large number of views on what socialism
actually is at this point
yeah and my view is that there's no
actual one correct view and to say
socialism is usually to say the
transitionary state between now and
communism a more organization based
version of what communism but but
communism is actually the state of a
stateless egalitarian society it's not
so much an actual most communist parties
yes do take power and and enforce but
that doesn't that's not the actual state
of socialism or sorry communism
communism is is the really the like the
end game of a lot of various ideologies
both anarcho and state oriented but I
would say that that's getting way ahead
of course we are yeah yes I mean I think
to bring it back a little are there
particular examples of not like I'm a
big advocate of within a particular
company saying this is going to be a
co-op right there's gonna be shared
ownership or we're gonna socialized
medicine I would argue those are
examples within mixed economies of
social democracy right is there an
example that you think we should look at
of an actual country level socialism
that that has worked well that would be
a model for what you want to see my
opinion is actually done right I think
that we've had a lot of attempts and a
lot of sort of we've had the military
coos we've had coops and communes
organized but as far as I'm concerned to
see the sort of mass level type of more
horizontal organization that I tend to
talk about I mean we're talking about
something that's a large country so no
we have nots I'm constantly talking
about it in terms of a large scale
operation so I don't know that there's
really anything that could be pointed
you could point to things like the Paris
Commune and stuff but that was
obliterated by a military operation so
yeah now you mention that again I think
that's more an example
of social democracy which is a commune
decides to organize within a mixed
economy I think that can work really
well but again I'm open to having my
mind change I've just not seen the macro
example of how it would work without
becoming like you said an authoritarian
top-down thing potentially imposed by a
military yeah and again what we end up
doing I think in sort of social
democracy or socialism debates yeah I
think we end up creating the sort of
it's a dichotomy that doesn't benefit
socialists or Social Democrats I agree
it's an argument as opposed to how do we
actually materially improve the lives of
the people now if the entire world
became a social democracy and people
wanted to keep progressing where would
it go from there would it not be more
moving towards collective ownership of
the means of production I think probably
but the reason why like you said I think
something like the Paris Commune may
trend a little bit closer to social
democracy than maybe full-blown
socialism or communism is if you think
about it if you exist within a
capitalist world it doesn't matter how
socialist internally you are you have to
interact externally as a capitalist
nation you can't avoid the fact that
worldwide we're capitalists that's just
and you know what I mean
I I do and I'm guessing you think that's
bad and I think that there may actually
be that there may actually be reasons
where if you operate more as a social
democracy internally you'll get a lot of
the benefits of socialization while
still operating in the world without
some of the downsides that we've seen
happen when countries do become sort of
authoritarian socialist well I think
that there's a certain degree of we
can't if we want to move in that
direction whether it's social democracy
or socialism we have to look at it as a
broad base of organization and I think
what will be will be more
so when we talk about organizing people
if right now today we mass and this is
obviously not possible to just do but
mass organized the entire United States
of America and the entire United States
of America said to themselves we want
social democracy then socialism wouldn't
be what happened but it would be the
will of the people which is in my
opinion a little bit more important than
ideological purity the actual
self-governance part of my beliefs like
I said I'm more of a libertarian
socialist than I am a authoritarian
socialist I think that it's more
important that the will of the people is
is heated now would that stop me from
going in and saying this is why we
should collectivise the means production
everybody no I would keep doing that but
it would be I believe in sort of just
continuing that discussion rather than
saying we aren't organizing the right
way I'd prefer social democracy to what
we live in right now yeah to put a sort
of final point on it that's that gets to
the pragmatism that I think also at
least in 2018 much more applies to what
would be considered socially democratic
policies than socialism but that's
probably a sort of different
conversation I want to make sure
everybody knows Peter doesn't just talk
about socialism he talks about call out
culture he talks about sjw's identity
politics you have a lot of great stuff
on your youtube channel I want people to
check it out Peter Kaufman is the author
of custom reality and you he has a
number of different youtube series and
you can find his channel on youtube and
also using the links in the video
description Peter really a pleasure and
I'd love to have you back thank you so
much I had a great time